Google cloud next 2017 hosted a huge
number of talks detailing the future of
cloud if you didn't get a chance to
catch the session saving money on
compute engine then stay tuned because
here's the recap the pricing philosophy
for compute engine is guided by three
concepts simplicity flexibility and
fairness we aim to make pricing as
simple as we can by offering
pre-configured products like n1 standard
that can be easily customized for your
workload similarly we know that at its
essence a VM is CPUs and RAM so another
way we keep things simple and
transparent is by not bundling other
components that create opaque SKUs that
hide the true costs in terms of
flexibility we focus on the concepts of
pay for what you use and buy only what
you need all clouds are pay as you use
but the way you count usage matters a
lot in practice in GCE we've had per
minute billing since day one because at
Google we understand that workloads
don't come in hour-long chunks we also
offer custom machine types including the
ability to efficiently schedule jobs and
VMs of any size a little over a year
after we launched this feature over 20%
of all compute engine workloads are
using custom machine types and customers
are saving an average of 19% from this
feature alone when you use our VMs
consistently it's more efficient for us
and we give those savings back to you
through sustained use discounts you
still maintain all the flexibility of an
on-demand cloud start and stop instances
in whatever way makes sense to your
workload and change your usage pattern
whenever you need we'll give you the
best discount that your usage qualifies
for automatically for predefined
instances we use a concept called in
third instances to calculate the biggest
savings that we can when we introduced
custom machine types we generalize this
model so it works even when the
thousands of possible instance shapes
that you can have with CMT if the graph
on the right is a picture of how you
actually ran a series of five different
VMs of the same size and shape it
doesn't look like you ran any of them
for very long I see what we do here is
combine similar VMs over time as shown
in the middle picture where we
reinterpret those same five VMs as if
they were three longer running VMs when
you look at those as a percentage of the
month you'll get
the max discount on one a healthy
discount on the second and the first
tier of discount on the third and with
committed use discounts you can get our
best discount levels in exchange for
telling us which resources you're
guaranteeing to use for the long term on
predefined types you can get a thirty
seven percent discount on one-year
commitments and a fifty five percent
discount on three years for custom
machine types the discounts of forty and
fifty seven percent respectively with
our right sizing features you can focus
on bringing your workload to the cloud
and once it's running we'll watch your
CPU and memory utilization and give you
recommendations to help reduce costs and
by using preemptable VMs a class of
super low cost VMS that are optimized
for short term use you can save up to
80% off the list prices preemptable VMS
are ideal for fault tolerant large scale
workloads that can handle single workers
occasionally failing or disappearing and
finally there's our autoscaler because
we don't need pre-warming you don't have
to pay for idle time while VMS are just
sitting around similarly because we can
boot VMS in about 30 seconds and scale
down in 60 seconds later you're not
paying for extra boot or idle time to
hear some real examples of how customers
spend money in the cloud and how the
Google pricing philosophy and features
described here can help you save more
money check out the full session on the
Google cloud youtube channel and for
more information on saving money with
compute engine check out the full talk
on youtube if you're looking for more
recaps on great next content make sure
to check out the rest of our playlist
and don't forget the next world tour
coming soon to a city near you
[Music]
you